welcome to hawaii everyone's favorite
show of the week
let's freakin do this oh boy can't wait
to read a bunch of james charles
memes that are gonna be slightly
outdated yay
[Music]
it makes me so mad that british people
say the c
word in every sentence like uh that one
is actually awful
please stop what consent
oh oh how to spot a slime bag people
that tweet these things
there you go it's always the one that
say these sort of things
that are are doing it to cover up from
something else
i think no one asked the fat rat is at
it again youtube suspended
my channel with 3.6 million subscribers
without
any explanation or warning and without
having a strike this is so crazy i don't
even know what to say
wait didn't something else happen to
this guy already about like a copyright
strike
all right this is still down though it's
it's back up
we did it ready good job ready just got
the message that my channel has been
reinstated it's been a rough mother's
day and sleepless night but also been
heartwarming see all this amazing
support thank you so much
see this is crazy to me because
youtube's algorithm is like
strike first ask questions later
he might have waking up one day and then
your live what your livelihood depends
on is just completely gone
this happens so many times to so many
channels how is it possible
by the way guys the pewdiepie
glow-in-the-dark shaker cups have sold
out
i'm so sorry this is you when you
realize you never bought one
[Music]
five million in six months never done
before
30 million in six months never done
before minus
three million this is so outdated i
can't believe he lost three million in
two days
never done before you did it james
charles
congratulations it's crazy logan paul
gained subscribers
out of his controversy can you
i don't know it's insane oh my god
boys i spent 24 hours in
straight in slime i spent 24 hours in
slime
and it was a huge mistake
it's like the original and then the
cancer version of it i spent 24 hours
straight in an insane asylum
i spent 24 hours in insane asylum
challenge
i put 100 million orbeez in my friend's
backyard
i put 100 million orbeez in my mom's
prank mr beast caught on i spent 24
hours straight in prison
challenge oh god and he just copied it
jesus christ dude
i think i i pointed it out in my video i
don't know if it made the cut but i was
like wait is he just copying mr beast
well i guess he is 100 does he at least
acknowledge it
because otherwise it's pretty messed up
dude
oh my god
that's beautiful thank you old house
pedro
ten out of ten jesus christ he's staring
into my soul
it's like he can see my beauty i love it
when you notice how
irrelevant t-series is after the meeting
most people didn't even know who they
were before all this honestly
best rose ever tati congrats on 50
million
been here since 16. can't wait for james
charles to hit 10 million so he can get
his diamond
play button playing james charles next
video
five subscribers oh my god thank you so
much
i mean it is kind of funny as much as i
don't like to admit it
the memes are good fame power and fat
bank account will change
almost anyone not me
i still well that is a fine car the
nissan
it is a fine vehicle to say the least oh
my god brofist statue
finally done
you gotta get it red though it looks
like a brain
i mean it's amazing i love it thank you
so much
finalize my prom outfit today damn is
that a pewdiepie tie
hell yeah it is oh my god let's sneak
out may 9th
pro jared became the first person to
lose 100k subs in a day
may 10th james charles became the first
person to lose
1 million in a day poor jared lost his
marriage dignity career and now he lost
his sub loss
record
god damn it i wish i didn't read it
before pub g apex lightning strike theft
auto you picked the wrong house fool
am i allowed to do a black man voice but
he says it that way
brad will decide thanos goes to mars
without elon and they talk about memes
while smug what in the world
oh okay because all the different
endings yeah i guess that's good i don't
know when you go
against the whole class and your answer
turns out to be correct
they called me a man me when i went
after tati ever
when everyone wanted blood for james oh
my god
you see in my artificial legs we've now
introduced so i can feel pain in them my
pb hard
ricardo milos james charles jk rowling
turning straight
guys gay hey maybe
just maybe i have this crazy idea
maybe if you can be convinced to sleep
with another man or make out
then maybe you are not straight i spent
120 hours making this it's my cake day
brad is gonna cut that out please can
this get to the y
this will probably get seven upvotes
bounce needs to see that
20k upvotes yeah that's usually when i
cut the episode
because around 20k it's all it's the
wild freaking west can you not repost
for five minutes the subreddit is fine
did you get to burst simulator yes
what did it cost nothing and that's a
great price
that's weird i don't think this
character is in tuber simulator
[Music]
that's strange ending the subscribe to
pewdiepie meme i broke my ass
i broke my ball i like how i premiered
it as well
and the chat just went f the whole way
for hours
oopsy doopsy james charles kinda used
his fame and power to get straight
people into gay also pewdiepie
sorry guys someone makes an oopsie
gloria burger gloria borge is fired i'm
sorry guys
she didn't do enough research i had to
let her go
a royal wedding the royal wedding like
that this is full bloom
summer and my face could not be any more
white i had not i've literally spent the
whole summer just making videos
i remember it so much when you're fat a
failure in school and don't have
a girlfriend but your meme makes it to
lawyer
i'm still worthy yeah okay sure whatever
you got to say to yourself
worst youtube channel nine euros
assembled this was made like five years
ago
when people used to hate me oh how
things change oh wait
nothing's changed we've gotten some
requests by our fans to have you on
the off the pill what do you say you're
down well there's never been a more
convincing argument of
other people want you to be on our show
so i mean how could i refuse
other people have told us this so
therefore i suppose
we will ask wow really guys you want me
on the show why thank you so much
i'm joking uh i would like to be but
podcast is like a double-edged sword
okay i committed to this analogy i guess
i don't want to do them and i'll
probably just get say something that
gets me in trouble
there you go mom can we get
mitzi at home we have mercy at home i
can't even read
marziano oh she looks so much
better wow gotta feel gotta feel good to
be
like the the ugly version of the meme
the ugly version of the joke how does
that feel dave
dave you're beautiful don't listen i
broke my boss
hey i remember touching your balls lol
thanks ball doctor
for at least remembering fame power and
fat bank account will change
almost anyone
aloha that's a meme now oh there it is
again
fame power and fat bank account will
change almost
everyone anyone i'm a maverick now
it's rare to see 96 million of anything
i saw that video and i remember the
title as well i think it is like
96 million i'm speaking the language of
guards
six three three six three three
it sounded like leaving
hey i almost got it
leave your entries in the subreddits
ah whatever
that's not what it is anyway i got
sidetracked
[Music]
god damn it god damn it i'm so stupid
god damn it edit that one out brian
pewdiepie felix irvin congratulations
for surprising
100 million subscribers hashtag thank
you pewdiepie
i'm a burger this is the final draft
okay
you might want to just another draft
maybe
just maybe just one more
can't you do the i mean i don't want to
criticize it but like why the yellow
font and like the font itself is kind of
ugly i'm not i'm not being ungrateful
and also like the brofist logo i know
that's very popular but i don't
generally use it that much anymore i
think
this is certainly interesting 2016
2019 you know that there's a problem in
the video quality from 2016 is better
than the quality now
that can't be right tell me what isn't
better haircut
i went to this [ __ ] hairdresser that
was like hey let's do something
avant-garde and i'm just sitting there
like
okay ah not again why does it look so
bad you're right
it it does not look this bad when i send
off the footage
it does not it does not i created a
hundred milliseconds play button concept
for appearance as a 3d model took me two
seconds
two seconds what that's a lot of little
that was cool though i like it why
is millennial humor so weird
why is dr phil so beautiful 2016
pewdiepie
every company that makes a game free is
just stupid the game is available
for free and that's a great price
well i talked about this before but
everyone was so
pissed that we charged money for legend
of the brofist and we thought we did the
right thing we're like hey it's a full
game
you can just play right away and then i
was like it's not free so it's like well
frickin then we'll just make a free to
play game pewdiepie i see you follow me
that's good because i saw your video the
day it came up
i love to do a sonic community review
i'll send my skype info
okay let's get the ball rolling i'm
sorry i've been very busy
it's happening my mailman is showed up
okay
[Music]
okay that was it for this week's levi
thanks for all the amazing memes and all
the amazing times
and all this amazing support and most of
all
thanks brad for editing this video
that's incredible that he does that
and i see you guys tomorrow that's right
tomorrow
i'll be here tomorrow i don't know why
every time i do the outro i'm like i
just want to sit down
why do i even film these standing up
it's very tiring to stand up
i don't like standing up okay end of
video
see you bye bye bye hey um
100 mil soon so make sure to subscribe
it's over there
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
you